Okay, so we are getting winked and.
We play E4, and of course, we play our
favorite Aleppan Sicilian.
Let's see how the Aleppan holds up at a
very high level, at a 2 ,000 plus level,
Knight F6.
As I said, at this level, we're
essentially exclusively facing the two
main responses to the Aleppine.
The first of which is D5.
We face that move a lot.
We haven't faced Knight F6 as much.
So this is a great opportunity for us
to review some of the theory of this
line and for me to show some new,
exciting analysis.
So after Knight D5, we already kind of
need to get into the weeds because
there are essentially two.
fundamentally different ways of playing
the Aleppan.
The first is the more traditional
approach, which is to play D4.
this position.
This is what you might have seen.
Then Black plays pawn takes d4.
And notice that in that resulting
position, White doesn't have to
recapture on d4 because d takes c3 is
not a threat.
The queen x -rays the knight.
So the main line is d4, pawn takes d4,
and then actually knight f3 is a very
important inclusion.
But recently, Aleppine experts have
embarked on a fundamentally different
approach, a more exciting approach that
leads to far more tactical positions.
Rather than playing d4, It is worth
starting with the move Knight F3.
In many cases, this transposes to the
main line, generally Black plays Knight c6.
then you might think that white has to
play d4 black plays pawn takes pawn And
we have ourselves the main line of the
Allopan, but...
After Knight c6, there is a second
approach, and this is the approach I'd
like to introduce you to in this game,
assuming that our opponent plays Knight
c6, which is not a given.
Black can also play d6.
Black can also play e6.
And those are the three main moves.
Knight c6 is on the board.
Does anybody know what move I'm implying?
This may seem.
Okay, depending on how you look at this
move, it may seem very natural, but
upon closer examination, this move may seem.
to be a serious positional mistake.
I'm talking, of course, about Bishop to C4.
We bring our Bishop out straight away.
We hit the Knight on D5.
and we're essentially forcing the
knight to move back to b6 or black can
also support the knight with e6 which
is a very popular move.
I don't think it's a very good line for black.
I am really hoping to see e6.
I think those positions are really,
really fun to play for white.
But so are the main lines after an ITP6.
In which case, we drop our bishop back
to b3.
Why did I say that this may seem like a serious?
positional mistake.
Well, we're actually encouraging black
to play a very scary looking move here.
Our opponent didn't play it, and that's
the move c4.
And C4 is scary because if we then play
D4 at any later point, Black can en
passant and break up our pawn chain.
So it may seem like we're going to end
up losing our E5 pawn.
And I'll show you some of the theory
after C4 based on the new.
Svidler Chasuble course, as well as the
Kalofman Bible.
And those lines are incredibly fascinating.
What you will see.
is that we often end up sacrificing the
e5 pawn.
And we go for rapid fire play on the
queen side and in the center.
And I think this line has breathed a
lot of new life into the Allopan.
So...
Some exciting stuff coming up after
this game, but D5 is the traditional
main line.
This is how people used to play this exclusively.
Uh, you know.
15, 20 years ago.
And here we need to not miss the
opportunity to take on Passant.
If we don't take on Passant, Black gets
like an ideal setup.
by bringing their bishop out to G4.
So without question, we need to take
Ampersand and keep the diagonal for
this bishop open.
And now, we need to quickly develop our pieces.
You may.
be attracted to the possibility of the
immediate D4.
but we're not really aiming to play a
quick D4.
That's not the point of this particular line.
The point of this line is to quickly
develop your pieces and actually go
after the B6 knight.
And you might say, oh, after the b6
knight, how on earth is that possible?
Well, there is a very important idea
and by carrying it out, you're lighting
the fire on the queen side.
But first, first things first, we need
to get our king out of the center.
And you need to realize that Bishop g4
is an incredibly common blunder in this position.
It walks right into the common tactic.
Bishop takes f7 check.
I've won.
countless games like that, even against
other GMs.
And after Kxf7, it's the classic Ng5
check, we pick up the bishop with interest.
Bb6 is the main line.
And this is where things get really interesting.
Traditionally, the main line has always
been Night A3.
And if you've watched the Aleppine
speedrun videos to date, you will know
that Night A3 is a very.
Classic developing move because the
Knight aims directly for B5.
So that's what people used to play all
the time.
And then recently, a new idea has taken
the Aleppine by storm.
Here's what it involves.
First of all, we trade bishops on e6,
and we do that in order to buy
ourselves a couple of tempi.
What does that mean?
Well, we're making it difficult for
Black to develop his king side, right?
Black would love to play E6 on the next
move, but.
He can, he's got to move the queen
away, and that costs black a temp, or
black has to fianchetto the bishop, but
that's two more tempi.
And we use these tempi to develop...
Rapid play on the queen side who can
tell me what idea I've been implying
for a while now It's not D4, D4 is
again, the traditional way to play.
We go after Black's knight on b6 with
the move a4.
An idea that you should be familiar with.
because it's universally applied in
many different types of positions.
We're shoving this pawn down to A5.
You might look at this and say, well, I
don't get how this is dangerous, right?
The move a5 is just a one move thread
and the knight has plenty of retreating squares.
Hopefully.
The course of the game will reveal why
A5 is actually a dangerous idea, and
it's not because the knight on B6 is
somehow in trouble.
It's because we're trying to push this
pawn all the way up to a6 and create
long -term weaknesses.
for black on the queen side.
In particular, some of the light
squares are gonna become weak.
And believe it or not, the pawn on a seven.
is going to become a long -term weakness
once it is fixed in place.
by our pawn on a6 of course if black
plays a5 here which is a legitimate
move then the knight on b6 loses its defender.
Black creates a gaping weakness on B5,
which we can immediately occupy with
our knight.
And at the right moment, we will play
d4 and blast open the center, and there
might be hell to pay for Black if he
makes too many weaknesses on the queen side.
Yeah, of course, Rookie 1 is a move that...
Most of you are gonna be tempted to
play, but remember the sort of
philosophy behind this line.
It's actually a good thing that the
queen is on e6.
It's making it difficult for black to
get the king side pieces out.
So, Rook e1 would actually help Black
by forcing the Queen back to d7.
We don't want to play Rook e1.
unless there's a compelling reason to
do so.
Very instructive point, by the way, right?
You can see how, at this level, these
tempting -looking moves are actually
often bad.
Queen d7, so our opponent is abiding by
the sort of clear strategy of kingside development.
That means we have no time to waste.
We need to continue our queenside
campaign with a5.
And this is still theory.
Queen d7 is, I believe, the main line.
And don't worry, we are going to play d4.
We're just waiting for the perfect
opportunity to do that.
Nighty -five.
So we need to complete the picture on
the queen side, what we do not want to allow.
is we don't want to allow black to play
a6 themselves.
because then our pawn on a5 becomes a
very serious liability.
It's a liability because, well, because
the knight on c6 aims at the pawn and
we don't want black to freeze the queen
side before we've done our job.
We want to freeze the queen side on our terms.
on our terms, which means we want to
throw in the move A6.
And as I've explained, we're trying to
induce the move B6.
And it may not seem like the weak light
squares on the queen side are
accessible because we don't have a
light squared bishop anymore.
That bishop got traded for its
counterpart on E6, but there's a piece
called a queen and queens also move diagonally.
So the queen is going to be ultimately
the vehicle that we're going to use to
try to exploit the queen side light
square weaknesses.
I'm anticipating the move B6.
If Black doesn't play B6, then we will
take on B7 and shatter Black's entire queenside.
If Black plays Bxa6, the same thing
applies, and...
Black merely invites our Rook onto a
super active square.
B6 is played.
now again we need to be very accurate
because if we fall asleep then black is
going to play e6 and bishop e7 and
these squares look very nice but we we
actually need to develop the machinery
in order to exploit them.
In particular, we need to combine
positional play on the queen side with
a general approach.
that involves making it as difficult as
possible for Black to develop his bishop.
Right, we want.
black to remain frozen in place on the
king side because it's going to make it
difficult for black to protect some of
these weak squares and the weak a7 pawn
on the queen side.
This means that it's the perfect
opportunity for us to strike in the
center with the move d4.
And this might be the last opportunity
that we're going to get.
So we need to jump on the opportunity train.
before it's left the station, D4.
Opening up the center, and not forcing
Black to take on d4, Black I guess can
also play the move e6 here.
We'll cross that bridge if we get there.
But the point, and hopefully you're.
starting to form a clearer picture of
what it is we're trying to accomplish here.
If black takes on d4, which is what
most people will play, then we take
back with the knight.
And if black takes, we take back with
our queen.
what is our queen on d4 going to be
doing well first of all it's in the
center it's supported by a c3 pawn but
most importantly, it's aiming at the G7
pawn, so it would have made it very
hard for Black to bring his bishop out
of F8.
E6 is on the board.
I'm impressed with the way that our
opponent has handled the opening.
Let me think about this for a second.
I don't remember what the theoretical
move is here, I have to think about this.
So I think it might be night a three.
I think it might be night a three, but
I'm not totally sure.
So.
I need a moment to think here.
It's, I mean, C4, C4 is a very tempting move.
But the problem with C4 is that it
opens up new prospects for Black's Knight.
It allows Knight D to B4, so I really
don't like C4.
Our pawn chain in the center falls apart.
Hey, Hannah.
Okay, there's also 95.
Oh, it is 95.
I think the move is actually 95 here.
I suddenly remembered.
that I'm pretty sure the move is 95.
And 95 is a hard move to explain.
So assuming I have this right, I'm
gonna wait until after the game to kind
of fully flesh out.
motivation behind 95.
Long story short, we're inviting a
night trade.
And we're changing the nature of the
pawn structure, right?
Once the pawn repositions to E5, the
pawn structure changes completely from
a potential IQP structure.
to a structure that arises in various
Allopan lines with that pawn lording
over black's position from E5.
And you should sort of understand why
the pawn on e5 is so powerful, because
it's controlling two very important
squares, f6 and d6.
Black would love to bring the dark
-squared bishop to f6, ultimately.
and black would love to have the f6
square for the night in the event that
white plays c4 for example So, after
the trade of knights, the d -file opens,
and white...
being the more active side with better
placed pawns and more space.
is more well -positioned to exploit the
opening up of the D -file.
There's also a very important idea
without which...
this approach wouldn't really work,
which is that.
After the trade on E5, which has just
happened, I'm assuming our opponent
will play Bishop E7.
Who can tell me?
and having knowledge of typical Allopin
ideas really helps, what's a very
typical way to meet Bishop E7 in these
types of positions?
This should be largely automatic for
you, this type of move.
It's Queen g4, it's Queen d1 to g4.
I know it's funny that we haven't
brought our minor pieces out.
This is ultimate modern chess.
Black can't punish us for that because
our king is very, very safe.
Queen g4 is super, super strong because
after black castles, we can bring our
bishop out to h6.
And that is the crux of why e5 is so strong.
Bishop f6 in that resulting position
would not have been possible, so black
loses the exchange.
But.
All of that is a moot point because
Black delays the move Bb7 and instead
plays Rd8.
Let's think about what our priorities
are in this position.
So.
First of all, we should not forget
about the long -term weakness of the A7
pawn and the best way that we have to
exploit that.
is ultimately to get the knight around
to b5 what would the knight on b5 be
doing well obviously it would be
pressuring the a7 pawn and keeping
black's queen at bay So one idea is to
immediately play the move knight to a3
and develop our knight.
Also.
The knight could potentially access the
d6 square.
I understand that there's a bishop
here, but maybe the circumstances will change.
There are other candidate moves.
There's the move Bishop g5, which I
don't like because it invites a Bishop
trade, and I think our Dark Squared
Bishop is a very important asset here,
which could drop, pay a visit to H6,
such as in the line that we were just
talking about.
So between those two developing moves,
I like Knight a3, but there's a third
type of move that we could play.
We could preemptively move our Queen
either to f3 or even immediately to g4
in order to make it as difficult as
possible for Black to bring his Bishop
out to e7.
Queen g4 would walk into the rather
annoying move h5 And if you drop the
queen back to G3, Black can keep
shoving the pawn down the board with H4.
So I'm not...
Convinced that that favors white So
from that perspective, I like to move
Knight a3.
But I like both of these moves, 9a3 and
Qg4 both have their pluses and minuses.
Let me think about this for a second.
Which of these do we want to choose?
I think.
I think we should play Knight A3.
It just seems...
To me?
that Knight a3 is the more flexible
approach to the position because we
don't know exactly where this Queen is
going to belong.
We can always play Queen g4.
Nobody's gonna be taking that move away
from us.
So let's start by bringing the knight
onto a square where it is ready at a
moment's notice.
to drop into B5.
And we want that ability because should
the Black Queen move away from the 7th rank?
then Night B5 is a potentially
devastating move, right?
If Black loses A7.
Even if it's the middle game, that pawn
on a6 is going to decide the game.
And that's, by the way, why we're
leaving the Rook on a1.
That may seem like a lame rook, but
oftentimes you want to leave it there.
for the occasion in which you take on
A7 and then you want that pawn to be supported.
So yeah, so many of you are suggesting
the move B5 here.
Yo, B5?
it stops us from playing Night B5, but
it also adds...
further strain to the queen side, right?
Because then the knight is
automatically pressuring the b5 pawn,
leaving the queen rather passive.
In response to that move, I like the
look of queen g4.
Okay, bishop e7.
Virtually forces our hand other than
Queen g4 we could still play Queen f3
But if we're bringing the Queen out now
We might as well use it to induce some
weaknesses on the king side Queen g4 is
an automatic move And you can see that
we're starting to squeeze Black, right?
Castles, Bishop, H6, loses the exchange.
And if we can force black to introduce.
king -side weaknesses.
Then Black will have weaknesses on both
sides of the board.
And we're going to keep overextending
black by trying to get the knight to be
five and in response to g6 bishop h6 Is
a classic reaction that prevents black
from castling.
We've got a big initiative here.
Now things that we need to be careful
about, obviously the E5 pawn has been
left without a defender.
and we need to keep an eye on it.
We of course need to keep an eye on our
A6 pawn.
Watch out for moves like knight back to
c7 and stuff like that.
And other than that, our position is
very easy to play.
We also should not get fixated on the
prospect of Knight b5 because in some
situations if the dark squared bishops
are traded.
As I pointed out earlier, knight c4,
knight d6 might be a more worthwhile
maneuver for the knight.
Another concept to keep in mind is the
move C4.
C4 is a move that we could play on demand.
And the point of C4 would be not only
to chase the knight away from D5, but
to open up the possibility of knight to B5.
Of course, after C4, the knight's going
to drop back to C7.
That's what we have to be very careful
about, because then A6 is hanging.
And.
We can't really go Knight b5 because
black has two eyes on that square.
So notice how, on our opponent's turn,
I'm talking about more general ideas.
This is the sort of classic.
Russian School of Chess recommendation.
I think Alexander Kotov.
who wrote How to Think Like a
Grandmaster, one of the sort of seminal
texts of the 20th century.
He advocated for this approach where
You use your turn to calculate concrete
variations, and when your opponent is
taking a while to think, you're
essentially developing.
conceptual wisdom about the position you're.
shuffling through typical ideas, you're
making mental notes to yourself, like
this is what I need to be careful
about, this is what I need to look for.
And in that way...
you're using every second effectively because.
On your opponent's turn, there's a lot
of uncertainty and your opponent has a
lot of options.
So.
unless you are fully anticipating a
certain response.
It actually makes sense to abide by
that advice, I think.
unless you feel like.
there's a lot to calculate, and you
really need to use every second to
calculate a certain variation.
or you're in time pressure.
In that case, it's all calculation.
Okay, Bishop f8, back.
Ooh, that is a juicy move.
That is a clear sign that our opponent
is in full backpedal mode.
Now.
Well, okay, how are we going to get to
Black's position?
First thing's first, there's a crazy
tactical sequence that...
I'm trying to puzzle out the move, Rook d1.
comes to my mind immediately as a way
to pin the queen and to threaten c4.
Bye.
If you look carefully at the move Rook d1.
Black could then drop the knight back
to f6.
And if we take the knight, then our
rooks are not coordinated, so queen
takes d1 as checkmate.
But if we look further after Rd1 Nf6,
RxQ, NxQ.
Our back rank is weak, so we can't take
on A7, but what we can do is trade
rooks on D8.
Finally, our knight gets into B5 and
the game is over because black loses A7
as a result.
So, Rook D1.
Looks very, very juicy.
It does in fact threaten the move C4,
not because C4 wins the night, it doesn't.
but because it forces the aforementioned.
transition to a winning endgame.
Okay, I need to think about this a
little bit more because Bishop g5 is
the second candidate move.
I like Bishop g5 just as much I like
Bishop g5 just as much.
I don't really see the downside of
Bishop to g5.
I guess the only thing we'd have to be
careful about is f6.
And as weakening as the move F6 is, it
buys Black a tempo, and I'm not sure.
that I want to part ways with even a
single tempo.
I also don't want to part ways with the
e5 pawn.
And Bishop g5 f6 essentially encourages
us to give that pawn away.
I don't like that as much because the
pawn is what's exerting the kind of
vice -like grip on black's position.
as crazy as it sounds, I'm actually
going to not play the tempo move.
which I think a lot of you would kind
of play automatically, right, Bishop g5.
partially also because I want to
maintain contact with the G7 pawn.
And I want to make sure the black is
not getting that bishop out anytime soon.
Oh, it's weird, but Bishop g5 is not
going anywhere.
You can really play this move now.
And now I think it would be.
even better idea because f6 is no
longer as dangerous of a response and
the reason why let's say we play bishop
g5 which we will Black will play F6, we
play E takes F6, G takes F6, we have a
check on H5 and the chief difference is
that Black cannot block that check.
on F7 with the Queen.
Right, because by shifting the queen to
c6, black has lost contact with the f7 square.
Does that make sense?
So now the look of Bishop g5 or Bishop
g5 looks a lot more attractive to me
than it did on the previous move If
bishop e7, then of course we take the bishop.
I think.
Or we play C4.
which is a move that.
has been, you know, that we've kept in
mind for a long time.
I think C4 might win the game.
after Bishop E7.
Now, could I have played c4 here?
Absolutely, I could have played c4
here, but the knight would have dropped
back to c7.
We would have traded rooks, and then we
would have delivered a check on g5, and
then we would have brought the other
rook to d1, and actually, probably that
would be, that would have been an even
better idea.
Somehow I didn't pay attention to.
the power of C4.
Yeah, C4 might've just ended the game, but.
Maybe not, maybe it would have allowed
the knight to...
sort of defend some of these key light squares.
I don't know.
Bishop g5 is is I'm sure going to be
good enough to win the game.
Yeah, C4 would have been very, very
explosive, but so is this move.
And we can play c4 on the next move.
It's not going anywhere.
C4 is not going anywhere at all.
But yeah, I'm a little bit bummed I
didn't play it.
right away.
But anyways, our opponent is down to
six and a half minutes.
You can just sense how much pressure
black is under.
Because all three sides of the board,
the queen side, the center, and the
king side belong to us.
We're in charge.
on all three sides, and when that is
the case, you can essentially rest
assured that you're probably going to
win the game unless you do something
really dumb.
What is actually the point of Bishop g5?
Well, largely it's to coordinate the rooks.
And why is it important to coordinate
the rooks?
Because after we play C4, we want to be
able to trade rooks and then bring the
other rook to D1 immediately in order
to grab control of that open D file.
But all of that's a moot point because
F6 has been played and this fundamentally.
changes the character of the struggle
from positional to now completely tactical.
Now don't give a check on H5
prematurely because that walks into G6
and we lose a piece.
At this point, we need to transform our advantage.
The e5 pawn has been the pride of our
position for so long, but now we
transform our advantage from.
that pawn being on e5 to the black king
being in mortal danger.
So you have to be ready and willing.
a moment's notice to give away
something that you're proud of and
something that you're hanging your hat on.
if you can understand.
that you're transitioning the character
of the advantage from one thing to
another, from positional to tactical, from.
domination over squares to a direct
attack against the king, which is the
case here.
is that hopefully that.
concept makes sense.
And the higher rated you are, the more
flexible you have to be in terms of.
changing your advantage from one thing
to another.
Okay, now, what was the critical move?
that wasn't as good with the Queen
being on D7.
It was a check on H5.
We forced the Black King out into the open.
And I made this move without any
calculation because there's no risk.
There's zero risk attached.
the move queen h5 check we know for a
fact that it's not going to make our
position any worse and so i made it
largely without calculation, even
though maybe just Bishop h4 would have
been just as good if not better because
now it occurs to me that the f6 pawn is
well protected and after Bishop h4 we
have to reckon with Knight f4 which I
completely missed.
But I don't think it's an issue.
So let me think about this for a
second, the move C4.
Remove C4 even here.
is very interesting.
Because after the trade on G5, the King
has to drop back to E8.
And then we don't even have to take the
knight immediately, we could even...
Pay a visit to the B5 square with our knight.
That looks really juicy.
We could also play Bishop h4, but then
there is this move, Knight f4, and it's
a little bit troublesome.
I will confess that was a very careless
moment by me.
So maybe, C4.
is not such a bad idea after all.
C4 f takes g5 Queen takes g5 King e8
Okay, then maybe we play knight to b5.
Let me, I'm just trying to make sense
of that resulting position.
and to really understand if it's
totally winning or if it's more
complicated than it seems.
I think it's totally winning.
My intuition is screaming to play the
move C4, and I'll flesh this out more
after the game.
but I just have a feeling that now's
the time to play c4.
Again, bishop h4, I was worried about
knight to f4.
And there are some tactics there with
Bishop takes f6 check.
King takes f6 and then Queen h4 check.
The problem is that black has a mate
threat on g2.
which doesn't allow us to pick up the
rook on d8, so.
I'll show this all after the game.
Right now we're low on time, so we need
to focus on the matter at hand.
So I'm fully expecting FG.
Okay, now.
It's important to be tactically disciplined.
We start by playing queen takes g5
check, and knight f6 is a blunder.
And this is.
Or is it?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, maybe it's not a blunder.
Oh my god, does he have Rook g8?
Oh my gosh, I think I blundered.
That is insane.
Man.
Okay, well I have to take.
I still think White might be winning
here though.
Oh my gosh, he's got Rook g8 in this position.
That is un -frickin' -believable, but...
I think.
but the position remains very
complicated even after.
we lose our queen, which is what is
going to happen.
I feel like our opponent missed Rook
takes D8.
and now gets lucky with Rook G8.
We have to sack our queen.
because if we move our queen, we get
checkmated on G2.
How do we get the most amount of
material for our queen?
We might very well lose this game now.
We play queen takes G8.
Leading to a fascinating position, two rooks.
for a queen and a bishop, which is
generally a decisive material advantage
for the side of the queen.
But the one caveat here.
is the presence of this pawn on a6
which is what we started everything
with we have to go after this pawn asap
which means we need to play rook b8 and
get this rook over to the seventh rank
and take on a7 try to move the rook and
basically we're praying at this point
i'm totally praying a black will not be
able to whip up chances against our
king in the time that I take to win
this pawn and move the rook back and
push our A point.
What's really helping White here...
is the fact that Black's minor pieces
are in terrible shape.
And it's gonna take like a solid two or
three tempi until Black actually gets
those pieces moving again.
And I feel like.
We might have just enough time to
orchestrate counterplay.
I think Wyatt is lost here.
Objectively, I'll be totally honest.
and I completely overlooked Rook G8.
I completely overlooked your G8.
but we got to bounce back and recover.
Now things are very interesting.
This is definitely the closest I've
been barring.
The games that I've played cheaters,
this guy's obviously legit.
This is the closest that we are to
losing a speedrun game.
Obviously, eventually, I'll lose a
speedrun game.
I cannot win a thousand out of a
thousand games, but this might not be
the one because I really feel like
practically, we have great chance.
There we go.
All right, the pressure is so immense.
Our opponent's nervous.
And immediately he blunders the bishop
and this should do it.
I really played that up, and then the
moment I said all those things, the
bishop is blundered right away.
Now, I'm actually fascinated by the
computer evaluation here.
I'm curious if White's actually better
in this position.
Yeah, White's not worse.
So it's equal with an only move.
No, White is winning.
I'm gonna check this on Stockfish15.
I'm going to check this on Stockfish15.
According to the Stockfish on Chess
.com, White is still winning here.
Let's check the actual eval.
And that's actually what we're going to
start with.
And then we're going to dial it back
from there.
Well, it's because of Rigby 7.
It's because of Rook b7 and Rook takes
a7, that pawn.
ultimately wins us the game, which is so.
Funny, because that's what we started with.
We started by getting the pawn to a6 in
the hopes that eventually.
our investment would be rewarded, and
so it was.
And so it was.
Okay, so let me paste this game into Chessbase.
And I'm going to run Stockfish 15, my
computer's going to protest.
All right, here we go.
So the evaluation after Rogue B8 is.
It is completely winning for white it's
plus five It is plus five for white in
this position.
Queen to a4 is the only chance for
black getting the queen behind the pawn.
Now white plays rook b7 check.
Kf6 and Rxa7.
After.
Black gets the night out?
I mean, Black.
just has no other way to get the minor
pieces out.
We simply play Rook a8.
attacking the bishop, and if the bishop moves...
You play Ace, oh, and this is beautiful.
This is beautiful, and after Kf7,
there's one more hurdle that White has
to cross.
See, the problem is, you can't move the
rook away because you give up a7, but
you can't move the knight because you
blunder the rook with checkmate.
But there is a very pretty idea that
allows White to circumvent these problems.
Who can spot the decisive tactics here?
It's pretty simple.
It's knight to c2.
You sack the knight.
then you calmly move the Rook to B8.
Black tries to generate counterplay,
but not fast enough.
We could even just move the Rook away.
We're not even rushing to promote.
Promoting also works.
But so does Rick F1.
Whatever, Bishop b5, we promote on the
next move, and we reach a technically
winning position, or white is up.
obviously a full exchange.
So just incredible illustration of the
power of passed pawns and the
importance of active pieces.
the importance of active pieces.
So it turns out.
If we rewind a little bit.
I'm curious if C4 was actually the top
engine move.
It was.
C4 was the best move and it was based
on a blunder.
but I just got incredibly lucky.
C4 is the best move.
The only move that wins clearly.
Fg queen g5 knight f6 rook d8.
Yep Take steaks and...
Rook b8 and white is winning.
Wow.
Okay, so.
With that in mind.
I got incredibly lucky.
It's like that joke about GMs throwing
the pieces up and it lands on the right square.
That's kind of what this reminds me of.
crazy crazy let's go back to the start
because there's a lot of theory to
unpack this is the opening theory speed
run and the hope is that by watching
these games you will essentially be
able to play the alapan just on the
basis of the speed run so knight f6 e5
knight d5 i'm not going to delve too
deeply into the theory of the
traditional main line which is d4 cd
knight f3 this is in fact what the
alapan bible recommends that's
squeezing the sicilian by khalaf one
and Solovyov, they recommend the
traditional main line, Cd, d6, Bc4, and
here the traditional main line goes
Nb6, Bb5.
You might be familiar with this line.
Sorry, d5 is a move, but De and Bd7 is
the main line.
This has been very well known for
decades now.
It's an IQP, structure -isolated queen pawn.
White has the bishop pair, but black
essentially has control of the square
in front of the pawn.
These two factors largely
counterbalance each other.
So the position is equal, but if black
opts for The most popular move, which
is Bishop b7, then black is slightly
worse after Queen g4.
See, it's the same idea applied in a
different position.
Black castles here, generally white
takes on c6.
Black takes with the pawn most of the
time, Bishop h6, Bishop f6, and Rook f
to d1.
And there's hundreds and hundreds of
games from this position.
White aims for e4 with the knight.
But recently, a couple of new moves
have been introduced.
In particular, the move Rook d8 is the
choice of a lot of top GMs, and it
basically takes this line out of commission.
Unfortunately, Rook d8 completely
equalizes because it puts a lot of
pressure on this pawn right away.
White castles here most of the time.
But ultimately, after e6, you're gonna
have to protect this pawn with this
very passive move.
Then Black plays Bishop e7.
And if you play Queen g4 now, well,
here Black can castle, and you've
already wasted a tempo on one
developing move.
Bishop h6 will make a lot less sense.
So long story short, the traditional
main line is good to know, but I think
there's a lot more meat on the bone in
the new Knight f3 and immediate Bishop
c4 line.
So after Knight b6, Bishop to b3,
there's a fork in the road.
There's two moves that.
are much more popular than the rest.
Of course, d6 is going to transpose
after pawn takes d6.
The first move is what our opponent played.
The second move is the immediate C4.
Followed by queen to c7 immediately
trying to exploit the weakness of the
e5 pawn This is why c4 is such a scary
-looking move, because if you say, well,
no problem, let me just defend e5, no,
black's going to en passant it, and
you're going to end up losing the
center pawn.
But the crazy thing is that the new way
of approaching this position is just to
sacrifice the pawn, just to give it away.
You castle here.
Black takes on e5, and this position,
believe it or not, is much better for White.
And as far as I remember, I'm going to
double check this, yeah, so the move
here is actually again a4, and a4 looks
laughably innocuous here, and you might
say, well, let's say that Black grabs
control of the center with d5, already
White is almost winning.
You throw in the move rook e1, right,
now's the time.
Let's say Black brings the queen back
to d6.
Now you play the move knight to a3.
So you're threatening to jump into b5
with tempo, so let's say Black plays
the obvious a6.
Now we blast open the center with d3.
And after the trade, the biggest
problem for Black is his lack of development.
Black just has a very, very hard time
getting the bishop out of f8, and if he
doesn't get the bishop out of f8, then
the king is not tucked away to where it
needs to go.
So if Black plays g6, then White wins
with the move queen to d4, attacking
the rook.
Black has to play this move, and this
is already completely winning for
White, a5, forces the knight back, and
now there's a beautiful move exploiting
the x -ray against White's king.
There's this move.
If black takes, then he drops the queen.
because you can't recapture.
If the queen moves, then the knight
maneuvers back to e3.
This is plus five because black can't
defend the d5 pawn.
e6 doesn't help, white takes anyway,
and black's position collapses.
So g6 is too slow.
What about e6?
Turns out e6 doesn't solve black's
problems either in this position,
although it's better than g6.
Here, white calmly develops the bishop
to e3.
It seems like Black is already knocking
on the door.
But the secondary problem, this is why
we've built the Bishop -Queen battery.
Black can't castle, still, because of
the checkmate on H7.
And this is an unsolvable problem
because it's not like Black can play G6.
And if Black plays an ugly move such as
f6, again, White strikes with a5,
brings the rook into the center, and
just look at Black's position.
Total and utter paralysis, and again,
Black can never castle.
And if E5, then no problem.
Drop the bishop back and D5 is now
incredibly tender.
This is plus two.
So, this position after a4 is
ridiculously dangerous for black and
understanding this fully is important
if you want to play this line successfully.
So what other sample lines could I show?
Well, what about the move A5?
What if Black just says, okay, I get it.
I don't want to allow you to push your
pawn to A5.
Well, now the B5 square is incredibly weak.
You already know how to exploit that.
The move is Knight A3, or you can start
with Rook e1, it doesn't matter.
let's say black plays e6 that's the
only feasible move the knight
immediately gets to b5 And if black
develops the bishop, again it's the
same technique, we play d3.
And the point of d3 is not only to open
up the center, it's also to prevent
black from castling.
Notice that if black castles immediately.
White can play D .C.
And after knight takes c4, white, of
course, has...
Queen d3, which is winning.
Also winning is to start with a rookie one.
And if Qc5, then White just tosses
Black around.
And of course, Ba3 ends the game.
Bb3, Black's position is in complete
and total shambles.
According to the engine, Bb4 is the
best move, apparently.
With the idea of setting up Ba3, you're
waiting for Black to go d5, and now you
play Ba3.
The reason is that Ba3 immediately,
Black can drop the queen over to g5,
and he's still kicking.
So you set up with Bb4.
You're threatening bishop to e3.
because you're taking away the c6
square from black's queen right bishop
e3 immediately black is still holding
on with queen c6 it should be four is
just classic computer chess And Black
is totally busted.
that doesn't work either giving up the
b5 square is suicidal which means
nobody's going to play a5 here But if
you don't play A5, we already looked at D5.
There's also E6.
but largely the tenor of the position remains.
unchanged.
You can start with Rookie 1.
I think this is actually the main line,
and this is the lesser evil for Black,
but again, you play the move d3, again,
by opening up the center, you're making
it virtually impossible for Black to
complete their development.
According to the engine, white is much
better, Bb7, and again, Na3.
And if black plays a6...
Then you push A5.
you centralize the knight, and you get
this massive clamp on black's position,
which overcompensates for the
sacrificed pawn, something like d6.
You could play queen d4.
encouraging Black to castle, but now
the bishop comes into the center.
And you've just have.
complete and total domination over all
three sides of the board, which is the
theme of this game.
So if black plays.
Knight back to F6, then we stick the
Knight right in Black's grill.
Then we can move our bishop back, and
this sort of resembles a Smith -Mora
type compensation, where you just have
domination in terms of your piece
placement, and black just doesn't have
any way to untangle.
Something like this is, I think, the
main line, and everywhere white is
objectively and practically much better.
And so this is what makes this line so exciting.
It's basically busted knight takes e5.
and it basically tells us that queen c7
which traditionally was considered the
line that everybody used to play white
played queen e2 automatically this was
what people played and then a couple
years ago castles became all the rage
and it virtually refutes the line with
c4 unless black plays d6 which is a
whole different line this is something
i won't talk about as much right now
just in the interest of time Here, it's
a very similar idea.
You trade and castle, and you quickly
play a4 and try to run this pawn up the board.
I'll leave the analysis of this
position to our next Aleppan game.
For now, let's address d5, because
there's a lot to talk about here as well.
Castles, black can play c4 here and
transpose into the position that we
just had.
Instead, our opponent goes for the main
line, bishop b6.
So here again, after the trade, 10 -15
years ago, everybody used to play d4.
This was considered mandatory.
And this line was analyzed to exhaustion.
You get this trade on d4.
And black has actually, I think,
several ways to equalize.
The simplest is, of course, to play
rook d8.
And there are some crazy lines here.
This is very, very theoretical.
The queen gets into e2.
But engines have completely exhausted
this line.
And black is fine here.
According to the engines, black is fine.
Black is equal.
So the move a4 has breathed so much new
life into this Aleppan variation.
And our opponent continues correctly
with Queen d7.
We push A5, we shove this pawn all the
way down to A6.
Again, B6 is largely forced.
And now we push D4.
So here there is, again, a fork in the road.
c takes d4 is the most common move and
after knight takes d4 if black
nonchalantly trades then black is
already worse because it's almost
impossible to get the bishop out of f8
okay and you might say well what about
a move like knight f6 trying to trade
queens well white is happily going to
trade queens here why because of the
weakness of the a7 pawn now the knight
has a ready -made pathway to b5 and if
black tries to prevent the knight from
reaching b5 it's going to move on to c4
and now it's threatening knight e5
check black's king is actually in
mortal danger here if king to d5 the
knight drops back into the center Yeah.
yeah let's say this move and now rook
d1 and after e6 the knight moves right
back to c4 and again 95 is virtually
unstoppable so it's the combination of
black's lack of kingside development
coupled with the weakness of the pawn
on a7 that makes this end game really
really bad for black And if black plays e6...
Well, now White's not in a hurry, and
we can work on our development either
with Knight a3 or with the move, Rook
d1, again, the Bishop can't come out,
and Black doesn't have any easy ways to
solve that problem, okay?
Hopefully this makes sense.
So our opponent plays a good move, e6
is considered, I think, the best that
Black can do, although maybe the more
accurate move order is to take first
and then play e6.
This actually might be the way that
Black wants to play this.
The downside of playing it like this is
that White gets now an additional resource.
Who can tell me what additional
resource White gets in this position
that we didn't have here?
Here we have, of course, the move,
knight e5, but in this version, White
has a sort of equivalently annoying move.
What am I talking about?
It's Night B5, it's the move Night B5,
which is kind of a major theme.
of this entire game is trying to get
this knight and ensconce it onto B5.
and This Knight is pressuring A7.
The theory goes on here.
You might have to check this with the
engine yourself.
I don't want to get too bogged down in
the details here.
probably already boring you as it is,
but I'm pretty sure that night be five.
is considered to be a small advantage.
For white and so our opponent's choice
to not allow that is understandable,
but this is incredibly Unpleasant for
black from a practical standpoint this
position is I think, I don't want to
say unplayable, but it's, I think it's
really, really bad.
So our opponent plays Rook d8.
and we work on our development with
Knight a3.
A lot of you were concerned about the
appearance of the move b5, and
remember, this Knight is completely chilling.
It's got tremendous potential energy,
and on demand, any time that we feel
like we want to involve this Knight
more directly in the game, who can tell
me how we can force this Knight, how we
can break through the shrubbery on the
queen side, if we want to?
We don't have to do that now, but on
demand, we can play the move c4, and
the Knight is feeling amazing on c4.
It's chilling.
It's threatening, potentially, to jump
into d6, and again, any time Black
plays bishop e7, we respond with queen g4.
And before you know it, black is
completely and utterly paralyzed in a
way like this, okay?
So.
b5 is not scary but we don't even have
to play c4 we could still play the move
queen g4 and keep C4 in our back pocket
for a rainy day.
B4 is not dangerous.
In fact, it merely encourages the
knight to get to C4.
And if black tries C4, well then black
weakens the D4 square and the knight
can take another route.
to get to this very nice outpost in the center.
Okay, so don't be afraid of moves that
stop your ideas because oftentimes they
create further weaknesses in your
opponent's camp.
Also understand that, yes, the knight's
on the rim.
And yes, it might not be controlling
any squares right now, but it's causing
tremendous strain.
on Black's position.
And that was the narrative of this
entire game.
Bishop e7 I think is a serious mistake
according to the engine Knight to c7
was the only way to preserve a feasible
position, but even here.
I think that white is significantly
better after queen g4.
And here the sacrifice is justified
because our pieces get into the game so quickly.
Watch this Bishop G5.
If bishop e7 Then we could even take
and whoop!
Quinn A4.
Four King, the Knight and the King.
And if King takes e7, then Rook d1 is winning.
And if black moves the Rook.
Well then, Rook FD1, I think, is game over.
Our knight comes in, the A file is open.
The A6 pawn is amazing, right?
It's such a strong pawn because if it's
captured, then the A file opens, and
that's in our favor.
If it's not captured, then we capture
the pawn on A7, and the pawn promotes.
That's why there's so much hype.
around this move, a4.
Okay?
So, Bishop e7, Queen g4, here our
opponent kind of panics.
I think King f8 would have been the
best defensive resource here for black, again.
castles bishop h6 illustrates the power
of this pawn bishop f6 is the move
black wants to play but can't so black
has to drop the exchange the other move
that black would like to play is g6 but
it allows us to stick the bishop right
in black's grill and prevent black from
castling kingside also very bad.
So I understand why.
Our opponent played Bishop f8, but this
just undevelops his pieces.
And now I think black is just lost.
Plus it encourages us to play Bishop g5
with tempo.
So I think King f8 is what I would have
played with black.
And we would have probably responded
with Rook to d1.
And now we're threatening to play C4.
According to.
The computer black is supposed to play
b5 here.
which to which we respond with C4 and
it's like plus one.
We just have domination on all sides of
the board, this is good stuff.
So in any case.
Bishop f8, rook d1.
and the tactical subtlety that I had to foresee.
is that Knight f6 is a.
Nice looking move because it forces the
Queen trade, but this is where The
power of the pawn on a6 is fully revealed.
Actually, we don't even need to rush
with this move.
We could first bring the bishop out to
f4 to protect d5.
That's such a patient move.
And you might say, but doesn't this
give Black a chance to rush the King
over to B8?
Well, yeah, but Rd1 ends the game
because this is a mate threat.
After Bishop b7, we got Rook d7, Rook
d8, and Rook b7 is made into beautiful
otherwise by the way the rooks would
have been forced off the board.
if we didn't have this operation.
Yeah.
Symmetrically, Knight takes a seven.
So it's a nice mixture of positional
and tactical ideas in this game.
Queen c6 is what our opponent did.
Now we bring our bishop into the game.
It turns out that f6 hastens black
demise, but in response to rook c8, we
would have definitely played the move
c4 and gotten the knight to b5 and you
can figure this out yourself.
This is completely and totally winning.
I think the simplest plan.
in a position like this is just a
double Rooks on the D file, which you
can do even after H5.
Although this is unnecessary, you could
just move your queen to the side.
Black has no moves.
Black is completely and utterly paralyzed.
And even if he takes on A6, we've now
transitioned our attention to the D file.
And Rook d8 is totally unstoppable,
Bishop e7.
Oh, we grab, we grab, and Quinn F6 is
gonna be made.
These lines are pretty one -sided.
What's up, Wangt?
My opponent in the chat.
Yeah, he says, I hated the A6 pawn the
second it arrived there.
No, that pawn is the bane of your existence.
So F6 is understandable.
and great job finding that Rook G8 resource.
It's basically pure luck.
Turns out the C4 is the best move.
And the reason I didn't drop the bishop
back is because of Knight f4.
And I was very tempted by this move.
And this position looks winning for
white, but it's actually winning for
black after king f5.
Because Black is threatening mate and
G4 check, the King tucks away on G6,
and here White can simply resign.
because of the threat of checkmate.
So you have to be careful until the end.
Don't fall in love with these tactical ideas.
You have to calculate them.
And just because your king is safer
doesn't mean.
that the complications are always gonna
work out.
in your favor.
That's why I played C4.
Of course, I was expecting King E8, and
here I think Knight B5.
is incredibly strong, much stronger
than taking the knight on d5.
because the night isn't going anywhere.
It can't move to C7.
Technically, it can move to E7.
I think the simplest approach here.
is actually well actually rook d1 check
wins the queen because king c8 knight
a7 is a fork And here there's 96,
followed by Knight F7 and Knight takes H8.
Another great illustration of not
getting fixated on checkmate.
Rather, you just win a decisive amount
of material and there's nothing left to calculate.
Okay.
Oh, don't spend your remaining time to,
oh, can I somehow use the discount?
No, just forget about it.
9F7, 9H8, the game is over.
There's nothing left to calculate.
So no matter how you slice it, either
white takes on a7 and retracts the
knight and then promotes, or we win on
the D file.
There's just too many areas of the
board where black is suffering.
Perhaps Bishop e7 is the lesser evil,
but we always have this check.
and the simplest is just to take on a7
and get this knight back to b5 this is
the simplest way to win followed by a7
and knight c7 And I was definitely you
know doubting myself at some points
It's crazy that rook g8 wins the Queen
But we have this magical resource Queen
takes g8 and rook b8 and there's just
nothing that black can do against the
threat of Rook B7.
That's actually what we started with.
We went full circle.
So don't feel too bad, Wank, that you
gave up this bishop.
Your position was lost amazingly.
is there's just no stopping this plan.
The pawn on eight six decides the game.
And, you know, great job for not sort
of automatically grabbing the rook,
which I think a lot of people would
have done.
This loses the rook on H8 and loses the game.
You paused here and said, wait a
second, my king is amazingly safe, but
I managed to maintain my composure and
find rook B8 ultimately just your minor
pieces are too passive and your queen
isn't able to stop the pawn on its own.
Okay, guys.
So thank you all.